there are hundreds of people here
preparing to sign up for the ukrainian
army but
just take a listen
it is curiously quiet
these are men they are all men lost in
thought they're about to commit to an
uncertain perilous future but here
you can feel the emotions that push so
many to volunteer
it's my duty i want to be useful i want
to help i want to protect i want to
fight back i want my family to return to
ukraine as soon as is possible and i
will do my best
down the road and they're waiting for
something different to get into the shop
that sells camouflage clothing and
military uniforms
many are keen to be prepared for
whatever comes next ukraine is a nation
that's coalescing around a war effort
we know why we're here we know why we
defend our country and our guys that are
actually standing there and fighting
our russian military forces they know
what they are doing those guys they
don't
we know what we are doing and that's why
we will win
in truth pride on its own won't win
battles
that needs people allied with purpose
ukraine's army has grown enormously over
the past decade it's now one of the
biggest in europe with hundreds of
thousands of other soldiers in reserve
and now across this country there are
these long queues of people ready to
volunteer as ever what strikes you about
the people of ukraine
is their determination their resilience
their spirit
over at levitz train station tens of
thousands of people arrive from the
nation's scorched cities in the east
lots of passengers flee west not many go
the other way
we meet mark who's come from bedford a
veteran of the british army he's now
here to fight for ukraine i asked him
why ukrainian people
the ukraine and military
zolensky everything is just better it's
been inspiring even like the country's
surrounding everybody's just like it's
like galvanized everybody's gavin hasn't
literally got a whole world weird enough
i've got no illusions i've got no
romantic ideas of war or like i'm going
to be some hero or make a difference or
any of this but it's
it's what i do
i mean you could die here yeah yes
possibility get wounded which would be
worse
with like life-changing injuries or
something
how long do you think you might be out
here from as long as it takes it depends
on the situation how it unfolds what
happens with me
this man waits to say goodbye to his
family they are going west to safety
he will now head east
to fight
for all the defiance ukraine is being
torn apart
adam parsons sky news live